The multiverse
it's life or death
you could use an avenger there are other
vendors we'll get you back on the lunch box
the fate of the multiverse depends on us no
pressure then doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness tickets on sale this wednesday
Welcome back everyone there's a brand new
marvel doctor strange 2 trailer video we'll break
down a bunch of new footage they're trying to be
as misleading as possible with it too so i'll
explain some of the easter eggs and what they
want you to think and what's actually probably
going on it wouldn't be a marvel trailer if they
weren't trying to pull a fastboot on you making
you think that someone else was the villain when
really something else entirely is going on most of
you probably have an idea what i'm talking about
but if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's a bunch
of brand new footage in here and obviously a lot
of missing footage too just in service of the way
they're presenting this trailer like you have dr
strange coming to ask scarlet witch for her help
in this big grove of trees like we've seen
a lot of the previous trailers talking about
this threat from the multiverse why he needs
her help please come help us it'll go a long
way to getting you back on the lunch box that's
actually a sly wink at the events of Wandavision
and what happened in westview in the previous
trailer she's like okay i expected you to come
at some point like she's expecting him to show
up and arrest her because of what she did because
in the mcu they actually clarified that she is
portrayed as kind of a villain based on what she
did in the hex she did legit keep those people
of west view hostage for a whole week just to
kind of live out her grief like i'm not trying to
hurt anyone i'm just trying to deal with something
i'm just going to be borrowing this entire town
to just play out this fantasy for a little while
the way that elizabeth olsen explained it at the
end of wanda vision the reason why she just kind
of takes off like you know what they'll never
know what you did and then she just kind of
takes off with a dark hole elizabeth olson said
that that's because she wanted to leave before
the police the fbi doctor strange legit showed
up to arrest her and take the dark hole from her
before she had a chance to study it i did a bunch
of videos for the deleted scenes for that final
episode they were going to have a couple doctor
strange cameos during that series especially the
later episodes but then the pandemic happened
and they had problem bringing some of the actors
back so some of the actors did not appear in the
finales much and they just decided to not include
doctor strange and switch it to a couple other
characters and save a lot of that dr strange
scarlet witch stuff for the events of doctor
strange 2 so him showing up to where she's living
right now here after the events of Wandavision
and she's been setting the dark hole for these
some months or so it's just them referencing
what was going to be happening during that
when she says there are other avengers out there
she's talking about the avengers who survived
avengers end game there have been at least
one new major avenger to join that shangship
she doesn't really know about the events of the
shangshi movie but she does know that some of the
avengers survived the events of avengers end game
but it does not include white vision because he
kind of screwed off at the end of Wandavision with
the hex vision memories unlocked inside his body
again and he's still dealing with those the life
or death scenario that doctor strange is talking
about the reason why he wants scarlet witch's
help at least at the beginning of the movie here
is because of the nightmare that he references
in the trailer that he keeps having every night
that he goes to sleep he's basically having a
nightmare about something terrible happening
something terrible coming from the multiverse
and ruining their universe the mcu he's also
still shaken about the events of spider-man no way
home with the two multiverse spells now remember
he also forgot peter parker but he remembers
that he weaved a couple multiverse spells
he still doesn't understand how the multiverse
works exactly at the beginning of the movie he
knows a little bit about it but he doesn't know
everything and even though during the first doctor
strange movie we did see him go on a magical tour
of the multiverse through different dimensions
most of the mcu characters so far that we've seen
like the regular characters cannot physically
travel between universes without really special
really dangerous spells that most of them don't
use so it's not something that's really common
right now that's where america chavez comes in
so before he learns what's really going on with
mcu scarlet witch pulling a fast one on them
he thinks that something really bad is coming
from the multiverse which is where the doctor
strange variants come in america chavez scarlet
witch's variant in the darkhold the main reason
why he wants the darkhold which he knows that she
has is because it allows him to weave chaos magic
like you see him using chaos magic here weaving
this quote-unquote forbidden multiverse spell
previously they made it seem like scarlet witch is
the only person in the mcu who's been able to use
chaos magic it seems like what's going on with
the dark holes and the spell that he's weaving
is it helps them communicate with other realities
see into other realities but it's actually america
chavez who has the power to actually punch through
different universes like this punching motion that
she makes is her literally opening a portal
a star-shaped portal like the one on her back
into other universes there's some misleading
footage of here of an attack on carmartage with
more scarlet witch footage but this is some of the
footage that marvel is making look very misleading
so that you can't tell who is fighting who what's
really happening here is the mcu scarlet witch is
fighting against doctor strange wong and all of
kamar taj using this special creation here with
the red eyes and the runes on it that's actually
being controlled by chaos magic she's trying to
attack comartage in order to get america chavez
like you see her floating here with this really
evil look on her face and the blackened fingers
kind of like agatha harkness's black fingers
everyone else here in kamar taj is trying
to protect america chavez to prevent scarlet
witch from forcing her to use her powers to open a
portal to the multiverse because the whole idea is
that she's been looking for a version of billy
and tommy clearly they're unsuccessful because
you see her strung up with this creation here like
this creature that's been created by chaos magic
or being controlled by it forcing her to open a
portal behind her remember the creature has the
exact same runes on it the gargantos does later in
the streets they're calling this gargantos in the
movie but really it's like a version of schumacher
that looks much more like shumigorth marvel just
has a copyright problem because the shumagorth
name belongs to the conan ip it comes from the
hiborian age and technically marvel doesn't
currently have the rights to the conan comics it
having those same ruins on it also makes it seem
like it's being controlled by someone else like
mcu scarlet witch you see the baron mordo variant
or it could be mcu baron mordo now with a really
long hairdo attacking rmcu doctor strange with
his sword weapon in the illuminati base he doesn't
have his cloak of levitation on like it's just him
in his very comic book accurate looking costume
there's much shinier clear hd footage here of the
maria rambo captain marvel variant working for the
multiverse illuminati team fighting the scarlet
witch variant if you pause on this picture here
you zoom in enhance and you look at the headpiece
here she has a really short hairdo it looks kind
of like an og version of captain marvel's mask
from the comics but on maria rambo with lashana
lynch's really short hair remember lashana
lynch played a version of maria rambo monica
rambo's mother the whole twist here is that in her
universe she just happened to be the test pilot on
the day the captain marvel got her powers instead
of carol danvers so she became captain marvel that
day instead of that universe's version of carol we
might get a little more footage of her in the next
trailer there's still a couple mcu illuminati team
members that we haven't completely seen yet but
i've done videos about them in my previous trailer
videos most of them are supposed to be variants
we'll see variants of fox x-men characters which
i think is probably the biggest thing everybody's
freaking out about but also probably some variants
of the fox fantastic four characters too then
there's been a lot of questions about this new
creature here inside the dark hole temple quick
explainer the temple that they're in here where
they're fighting if you look in the background
has the exact same markings that are on the dark
hold and it's inside this mountain range i think
the idea with the temple is that it's supposed
to be an easter egg for the one dagor mountains
in the comics in the chaos magic backstory in the
comics like scarlet witch's original backstory not
the mcu backstory like they're kind of trying to
do some easter eggs for comic book scarlet witch
the reason why doctor strange in the trailer is
able to weave chaos magic using the dark hold
is that in the comics they're trying to do an
easter egg for his creation in the comics it
was actually created by cathone the god of chaos
he's the person who created chaos magic and gave
that ability to scarlet witch when she was born it
was all part of a long play that he was trying to
manipulate her in events around her to use her
to help get back into the main mcu dimension
because all these creatures really powerful cosmic
beings really powerful gods are always way more
powerful when they're physically able to be inside
the mcu but most of them are trapped in alternate
dimensions with a fraction of their power now
this creature in the trailer is not supposed to be
cathone himself it's just supposed to be another
random demon being controlled by chaos magic so
notice the red eyes that denotes the chaos magic
being used to control it it's also the creature
that people saw in the poster and were like what
is this is this cathode is this something else
it seems like what's really going on here is that
the creature is probably just a servant of scarlet
witch so she either creates it or summons it using
her chaos magic the way they present it behind
wong here he seems super surprised by it at first
like wait what what is this then he turns around
away from it summoning his twin swords pointing
them at something else coming towards the entrance
of the cave and then the camera shifts to the
right to scarlet witch flying next to him with
her chaos magic at the ready like both of them
or all three of them including the monster behind
them are getting ready to attack someone else even
though they are trying to be very misleading about
what's going on here like isn't scarlet witch
supposed to be kind of the villain in the movie
it seems like at least in this scene they want to
make it seem like the zombie version of defender
strange is the bigger threat in the moment because
at the end of the last trailer it makes such a big
deal about everyone else freaking out at the sight
of him and it's taking place at the same mountain
range region like you see zombie strange at the
entrance to this cave i think it's also meant
to be a slight easter egg for the events of the
what if series with marvel zombies like a marvel
zombies easter egg but if there any other easter
eggs in the trailer that you spotted in the video
just write them below in the comments there's
supposed to be an even bigger trailer at some
point next week so of course i'll do a video for
that as soon as they release it cannot wait to see
some more of those fox x-men characters come back
everyone click here for my full marvel moon knight
episode 1 video and easter eggs and click here
for my full moon knight episode 2 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!